but we're rounding the turn drives them
crazy when i say we're rounding the turn
the only turn these people are rounding
is from one queue
into another at milwaukee's biggest
covid testing site
around one in every four people waiting
here
will test positive wisconsin
now one of the world's coronavirus hot
spots
eight nine hours a day every day and
it's non-stop for the most part
so close to 90 percent of wisconsin's
icu beds
are full this intensive care unit
already at complete capacity
a field hospital in milwaukee is taking
in patience
to help the stretched system but some
frontline medics are furious
washington is adding to their strain
and what's it been like seeing how the
pandemic has been politicized here
i find it maddening um you know
some people say they it's going to go
away on november 4th and
as you've seen as you came through our
hospital these are not people who are
political
consequences they are real sick people
with real viruses
donald trump ignored pleas from local
doctors to cancel tuesday's rally in
wisconsin
but this state was key in winning him
the white house
and his campaign went ahead in the
country's
covid epicenter all they want to talk
about is kovid
but the good news on the fourth they'll
stop talking you watch
they'll stop talking you get out that
red wave
just get out we have to win this
election coveted outbreaks are already
being traced to previous trump rallies
and as the virus escalates at an
alarming rate
the stock market is tumbling but that
hasn't turned away
many of his supporters here even ronda
who lost her father to the virus in
april
so even with what your family has been
through donald trump has your vote
yep he did he did well the last four
years even with the democrats
fighting everything he ever did we are
100 donald trump
i mean sure he could have done better
but
nobody's perfect i don't know what the
answer is but
is the answer holding a packed rally in
wisconsin
if it was an appleton i'd go really i
would go
i would go while wisconsin is breaking
records for coronavirus
it's also seeing records for voter
turnout
at the forefront of the election
battleground
and now the covid front line sally
lockwood sky news wisconsin